[Music]
God
first s அஹம்துலல்லா weஸ்ed 5 மிஸ் early
8 to 820 was the recap of the second day
of the international dawa tring prர 82
825 am we are reading out the schedule of
the third day of the international dava
training prர 825 to 1015 am for 1ஹ 50
minut you will all be learning the
techனக் of dawa related public speaking
handled by none other than drak இஷ we
will go for a teரak at 1015 am to 10:45
am for 30 minut which includes your take
asவ as your  bites your interviews for
the reality show insall then we  res the
second session 105
which up 1m
2ஹ 15 மி கation of techன of ரி பக்கங்
and 1ரஹ5
பm and 115 பm to 215 pm we the lunch
break இஷ  அல்லாஹ alongவி interviews
for the reality show followed by the
third session
ஸ் 215 பmஅன்
அ 415 பm 2ஹ அன்ஹ கation of technologyனக் ofரி
பing so you be wondering what are going
to  discஸ் coming on the stage giving the
spe so simple why should we discus it
for 2 4 5 moreத 6 to 7 hours up to 7
hours of learning of only the techniques
you will only realize once drak comes on
the stage insall
then we break for as sal at 4:15 pm up
to 4:30 pm for 15 minut 4:30 pm to 5 pm
we have the te break  session for 30
minutes and th the last session the fourth
session 5 pm to 6 pm we have the cross
checking of the names with meanings of
the first 25 of the Quran and as i said
day before yesterday late evening i made
a
25জ
50ஹஸ்
க மோவட்தன்ஹ
மோவ  இஷ அஹப
50 first 50சன்விங்ஒஹ
அ Maybe 2 hours 3 hours depends upon
your performances
and th 6 pm to 6:30 pm we will have a
quick revision of the Quranices with
translation helpful for dawa asவ as we
will also be dealing with the veres for
da 12 sets asவ as 14 sets of veres  for
the most common questions asked by
non-Muslims about Islam at the end at
6:30 pm ins we hope to conclude the day
on
கோ
மடன்ஷ அல்லாஹ
வில இவக்டி
நாயக்  கஸ்டேஜஸ்விம்
ஆடனக்ஸ்
ஆ தவாரிட்  பப்ளிக்ஸ்பீக்கிங் டாக்டர் ஜிர்
நாயக்
আলহামদুলিল্লাহ  Read more
আউজুবিল্লাহি মিনাশ শাইত রাজিম  Read more
Raise my chest, make my affairs easy for me, and guide him from my tongue, so that he may
understand. May
peace and God’s mercy be upon you.
the first two days
little spending with insall catch up
very soon as real that on the first day
we had the introduction of the
participants
and the second day we had a 3 minut prepared
spe which wasஹ given to all the parcip
including to brotherah
so i request him that if you can come on
the stage inod himself for about 4 minut
and formally close the introduction and
after that he can give 3 minut pr spe
and we can evaluate him to so that he is in
lineவி all of us  Requestah come in
the name,
prayers and peace be upon the best of humanity  Muhammad bin
Abdullah,
after greetings, peace, mercy, and blessings of God be upon you. And upon you be
peace, mercy, and blessings of God. My
name is Ibrahim bin Jumaan Al-Zahrani, a
19-year-old Saudi Arabian student. I have
also been walking with PV for the last
two years in associate management. And also, if I was a good person, I was a good person. I have a good life for someone for never.
I've never imagined my life full time, but praise be to God. Why only good Muslims? I am not a good Muslim. I am excellent for all
my kind as a
now in this tring
seeking to be. God willing. Praise be to God. Program. I want to be a good person. Praise be to God. In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. Praise be to God, and peace and
blessings be upon the best of creation. Praise be to God, and peace and blessings be
upon the best of creation, Muhammad
bin Abdullah. After greetings, the
Quran has been revealed.
Surah Al-Baqarah, verse 2. God
Almighty has revealed to you the Book in which there is no doubt, a guidance for those conscious of God who believe in
the unseen, establish prayer, and spend out of what
We have provided for them, being mindful of
God.  The
pious
invite him, invite him,
days
so that the invitation,
face,
like
Surah Al-Baqarah, "Indeed, those who disbelieve - it is all the same to them whether you
warn them or do not warn them - they will not believe. Allah has set a seal
upon their hearts."
Disbelievers, the
pious
invite him
for Islam origin, and they even though
in the, in the, it says the nonb sealed the heart sealed, but we are talking about the
people who are sealed, who are the invited to know the, the, and the message. Allah, Surah Al-Baqarah, hypocrites. And among the people are those who say, "We believe in Allah
and the Last Day," but they are not believers. They deceive
Allah and those who believe, but they deceive not except themselves.
They think they are with the Muslim, are hypocrites. Invite him, this is hypocrites. Indeed, all praise is due to
Allah, and peace and blessings be upon the Messenger. There is
no god
but Allah. There is no god but
Allah. There is no god
but Allah.
Muhammad is the Messenger of Allah.
[Music] Muhammad is the Messenger of Allah.
I seek Your pleasure, O
Allah. You are the Most Merciful, O Allah.
Grant me Your gift, O Allah. You are the
Generous,
and from You comes the gift, O Allah. You are the
Great, O Allah. In You is hope, O Allah. You are the Forbearing, the
Concealer.
[Music]
King of the King, the Forgiving, the Bestower, the Beneficent, the Exalted, the Compassionate, the Concealer, King of the King,
the Forgiving  The All-Giving, the Most Generous, the
Exalted,
Allah, Allah, O my Lord, O Allah, O my
Lord, O Allah